(audience cheering and applauding)
After failing to broker
the purchase of Greenland in Nuuk,
I headed north to give it one last shot.
(dramatic music)
This one here.
I brought you
[Conan] Look.
this little girl.
Oh my God.
Not to keep, obviously.
No, sorry.
(audience laughing)
(child giggling)
Oh, you got me!
(exclaiming)
(child giggling)
You like that one, you like that one.
Wow, look at that.
And there's a cruise ship.
Everyone on that cruise ship has diarrhea.
(child giggling)
(audience laughing)
That is incredible.
I don't think I've seen an iceberg before.
They used to be bigger.
About 20 years ago they were three times bigger than now.
Temperatures this July
smashed heat records across the globe,
and the impact was particularly tough on Greenland.
Nearly half of Greenland's ice sheet
began melting this week
after an unprecedented warm spell hit the arctic region.
Temperatures were more than 40 degrees above average.
[Helicopter Reporter] There's enough ice in Greenland
to raise sea levels by 25 feet world wide.
If unprecedented changes are not made, and made soon,
there will be irreversible damage to the planet.
Ah.
Broke again!
(child giggling)
With just an hour left before my flight home,
I was finally able to buy some waterfront property.
Okay, you get your ice.
We're getting really close, this is cool.
This is the dumbest thing we've ever done.
(audience laughing)
(dramatic music)
There's no way.
It's not even going in.
Oh wait, there's a little crack right here.
Oh props, (beep) props.
(audience laughing)
(audience laughing and applauding)
It just occurred to me,
it'd be funny if this is how the Titanic sank,
they were trying to get a gag iceberg shot,
(audience laughing)
and they got too close.
(dramatic music)
Here we go!
Ready?
Oh, we're already drifting away.
We've gotta go back.
I need to get down here.
(dramatic music)
(audience laughing)
Back!
Dammit!
(audience laughing and clapping)
Don't let it fall.
The sign's falling apart.
It's not gonna stay.
Do we have anything to fix this?
All right, let's go!
(dramatic music)
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
No icebergs were injured in the making of this video.
(dramatic music)
(audience cheering and applauding)